it's a little surprising to me that were
at this at this stage already we're
pushing the stakes higher and higher
every day my name is John Shriver I'm
the co-founder and CTO of frame i/o I'm
29 years old
so frame Iowa is a video review and
collaboration platform we offer users
the ability to upload to private
workspaces invite the people that need
access to that content and then those
people can do things like draw and
comment directly on video frames the
time-based comments and annotations do
version control and then eventually
share out with external collaborators
the branded presentation pages people
are pivoting to video because it's the
preferred way to consume information so
you'll now see your Facebook feed is
mostly videos you know whether that be a
news article or a recipe you know people
typically are reading as much as they
used to
I did I was introduced to coding through
college and that was image processing
and then I was able to kind of take on
my own for application development and
software I get a lot of credit to my
co-founder for guiding me into the tech
world and showing me kind of what could
be done we put a lot of time into
building the first version of the
product a lot of times the advice that
people hear when building companies is
to start very lean release a product and
then get feedback on that product and
iterate we kind of knew the problem that
we were trying to solve and we put a lot
of time up front to make it the best
solution possible and when we released
it it was it was something that people
knew they needed and they could have
instantly adopt
we pride ourselves on the culture that
we're building every my oh we have a no
rule we hire just very genuine
smart and slightly nerdy people
everybody enjoys working at the company
and that's something to also be proud of
the best thing is a sense of
accomplishment and that's what I I'm
always going for I just want to do all
that I can in the short amount of time
we all have on earth
you